[Music]
it's the top of the hour uh and it's
super casual so we can just get started
um you may notice
rachel is not here today so rachel is
usually the host of the data science
hangout she is
on vacation i will try to do her uh
justice and do the hangout justice but
i'm excited to uh see you all if you are
joining the hangout uh for the first
time welcome we're thrilled that you're
here the hangout's just a super open
space
participate as much as you would like
we do record the sessions so we can
upload them to our site and on youtube
so people can watch the recordings
again participate as much as you like
you can have your video on have your
video off
log out connect again
really the space is just for you
conversation is super casual and open
there are a few ways to participate
so you can anonymous anonymously submit
questions on the slido that my colleague
hannah
uh shared
or you can raise your hand uh and we'll
get to you or you can post a um
question or a comment in the chat
and hop on video and audio um but anyway
my name is rob i work at our studio
again rachel is on vacation this week
she'll be back next week and i am super
happy to introduce lindsay our uh leader
for today lindsay clark she's the
director of
data science um
at it is uh
i wanted to say blue book health but
that's totally i'm jumbling up the words
help me out healthcare bluebook you got
it
healthcare
yeah so maybe uh a quick introduction
who you are what you do and uh
yeah
yeah absolutely well thank you so much
robert um we'll get to it like uh robert
indicated my name is lindsey clark i'm
director of data science at healthcare
bluebook just want to say a special
thanks to
rachel robert for inviting me here today
i got to know the folks at rs studio
mostly at my last job where we had all
of our deployments in our we only have a
couple deployments in our at blue book
but we can talk a little bit more about
that as the hour goes on i'll give you a
little bit of background about me and
sort of how i came to blue book we'll
start with kind of present state i've
been at healthcare bluebook for
almost two and a half years so um you
know if you've noticed there's something
been going on the past couple years
which is called coven
so i've essentially
been at blue book during the entirety of
the pandemic so i started at blue book
about a couple of months before kind of
lockdowns for covet happened so i've
been
essentially remote my entire time there
so i lead a team of two data scientists
currently at blue book we're a company
of about 150 employees currently
so we're kind of billed as the kelly
blue book of health care
so if you think about that we offer fair
pricing and market pricing for different
health healthcare procedures
within a particular market across the
united states
do you think about it we don't shop for
healthcare the way that we shop for
something like a washing machine or
clothing
so really the mission of our company is
to change the consumerism of healthcare
and offer our clients which are
primarily employers and we work
primarily through brokers
if anyone's familiar with the healthcare
space
but we offer kind of direct to employer
benefits where
people can actually shop for healthcare
and save money if they go to a low-cost
high-quality facility in their area for
what we call shoppable services so
things like colonoscopies and mammograms
something that's planned or elective
is considered shoppable
sort of trauma and things like that car
accidents that's not considered
shoppable so we don't really cover
things like that
we do have price information for our
clients and as of last year
we actually went through a merger and
acquisition we purchased a company
called quantros located in greenville
south carolina
so we do have kind of a quality division
of sorts now which is very similar to
what i did at my last job
so we we provide algorithmic support for
quality models
for providers and hospitals
for different kinds of procedures and
patient outcomes
across the spectrum of health care
so that's really a little bit about blue
book
i'll give a little bit of information as
to how i arrived here and then we can
kind of open it up to audience questions
so
i'll try to make this short because my
journey to getting to blue book was i
guess a kind of a long one
i spent most of my life so far in
academic research that's beginning not
to be true but so i earned a phd in 2005
and for 10 years after that i mostly
worked in academic research
primarily within
basic science and drug discovery within
type 2 diabetes
and i returned to vanderbilt
in 2011 to do a post-doctoral
appointment which was unusual to work
for a while and then go back and do a
postdoc
but i was really kind of having a hard
time navigating my career i didn't
really know what i wanted to do
specifically i had kind of this idea
that i wanted to be a principal
scientist and pharma
but it wasn't really working out i had a
few
job interviews that that didn't really
pan out so
um ended up returning to vanderbilt for
a postdoc it was really kind of a
watershed time of my life i started sort
of figuring out that i really liked
programming i had gotten away from
mathematical modeling as a graduate
student and really wanted to return to
that
started teaching myself r
also started teaching myself python
at the time kind of 2014 2015 data
science was actually just so very new
um and everyone kind of in the national
market was talking about big data and
companies were hiring data science teams
so
actually i ended up
sort of befriending if you will
a startup company called axial
healthcare
which was the first company i worked for
they were in an incubator at the time in
nashville so the national entrepreneur
center is a singular
startup incubator in nashville
and so i just got to know them the the
chief science officer had actually come
to vanderbilt to do a career talk
and so
i asked her if i could come and shadow
the company periodically just to kind of
see what they're doing i wasn't really
sure what i was going to get out of the
experience
but i started doing that and
interestingly they gave me access to
their database which at the time was
google bigquery
didn't know sql at all had never written
a line of sql in my life
so
i did kind of some freelance work for
them it wasn't really anything
extensive
they asked me to do a few case studies
and make a few charts and
i i found it really compelling that my
work was kind of friend centered they
were pitching this to their potential
clients like the next day and i found
that really invigorating just kind of
the speed
of which they were moving and it seemed
very impactful
and so
i ended up actually like a few months
later it happened very quickly um they
got a series b round of funding um as a
startup and they were going to move
offices
and i remember approaching them in the
parking lot one night at like 10 30 and
i said i don't want to be presumptuous
but i really like you guys
i would be interested in full-time work
here if if you're interested in that and
they just kind of shook their head there
was like five people at in the company
at the time and uh two weeks later they
offered me a full-time job as a data
scientist
so that's really how i got into this
field
i was really kind of self-taught
for the most part
when i was in school data science
programs didn't exist it kind of wasn't
a thing
so i've really kind of forayed uh my
academic experience and research
experience into a data science role
about nine months after i started axial
i was promoted to director
and really for no other reason then i
was a really good individual contributor
and you know they they liked me as an
employee and they needed somebody to
lead the team so i was kind of there
and ended up building a team of about
five data scientists
at axial
they have since rebranded to a spring so
if you notice kind of some
differences on my linkedin page that
company is now called wayspring
but it was really a huge time of growth
for me
i started thinking very differently
about my role as a data scientist at a
company what is the value that i add
i really had kind of a mind shift
in terms of how i viewed data science at
a for-profit company and how i viewed
research at a for-profit company
um so while i was at axial i ended up
going through a six-month leadership
program which was kind of life-changing
for me
really started getting super involved in
my community i now co-organize the
national data science meetup i've been
doing that for about six years now
um
also really just started doing a lot of
volunteer work with local universities
and also boot camps just in terms of
mock interviews and kind of helping
students along the way
i think i personally struggled with my
career early on so
i really get a lot of
fulfillment um from helping others uh
within the community and sort of
fostering data science within the
nashville market
um so i do a ton of panels and speaking
engagements and and things like this
so i really enjoy that i'm also an
adjunct professor that's i guess my side
hustle
i've taught previously at columbia state
community college and then at lipscomb
university within their data science
program
and then as of last semester i'm
currently at middle tennessee state
university teaching
capstone research within their data
science institute undergraduate program
okay well that's a little bit about me
and how i got here
i guess i kind of missed that i
um did leave axial in 2019 in december
of 2019.
um it was really just time to transition
out of that company and i started
actually back in an individual
contributor role at blue book
so if anyone wants to know more about
that i'm happy to talk about that
experience but
i was a data scientist doing
really just a couple different projects
for the company for about a year
and then have been subsequently promoted
back to director at blue book with a
team of two
okay well i've talked long enough it's
10 11 minutes um so
is there anyone who would like to
discuss anything he wants to know about
healthcare my path
data science strategy which is very
close to my heart now
anything at all i'll kind of open it up
now
could i could i just press a little on
clarifying the business model so there
is a question anonymous anonymously sort
of about that like you know how do y'all
make
money but maybe paint a picture of like
how does a a company usually procure uh
i don't know healthcare solutions and
then what what what you all offer that
is different
yeah so
um
let me give for those of you who might
not be familiar too much with our health
care system
so
when you sign up for health insurance
through an employer
there's really kind of two different
flavors of that so
the the company could be at risk for
their health insurance or not at risk
and what that means is so small
companies typically aren't at risk
meaning there's not enough employee base
to actually have a meaningful pool of
money from your premiums in order to pay
out for health care services so those
are typically more expensive plans
now your larger companies like your
amazons your walmart's like really big
like fortune 500 1000 companies
those companies typically are at risk
meaning the the role of the payer is
usually administrative in nature only so
basically you pay your premiums and
those go into a pool of cash
and that that cash is used for your
office visits or your preventative care
or any surgeries that are needed so i
get this question a lot like how does
blue book make money um
so companies who are at risk they
typically want to preserve that pool of
money in a lot of ways
and the reason is because they they are
essentially responsible for it so
it it makes sense for their employees to
actually go to a facility for their
mammogram or their colonoscopy that's
quite a bit cheaper
but is actually similar quality to a
more expensive uh facility right so if
they're if the pool of cash you're only
paying let's say two hundred dollars for
your colonoscopy
versus a thousand dollars then the the
companies actually made
800 or conserve 800 let's say
now that's that's a very basic example
um but that's the reason employers want
to purchase our products is because
they they save money and conserve health
care dollars by using our product
so we
pretty much exclusively contract with
companies who are at risk for health
insurance
does that does that answer your question
it did understood um
and
the work that you're doing
within
blue book uh specifically you know how
is data science playing a role
okay that's a great question so we
really kind of have
at least now after the acquisition
there's kind of two elements of our
business one is cost the other is
quality
so
i'll start a little bit with the cost
piece so we do have an analytics team
that is responsible for
the strategy and algorithms behind what
is a fair price for example within
nashville or new york city markets or
wherever across the united states
what should we expect people to pay for
a colonoscopy like what would you expect
to pay for
a washing machine right like a fair
price might be 500 or something like
that
we don't really know that
for something like a healthcare
procedure
so really the goal of that team is to
look at the cost of different procedures
kind of the spectrum and spread across
colonoscopies that happen within that
market and determine from that
distribution what is the fair price
so we have an analytics team that's
responsible for that
and then kind of separate from that
we have
we offer information
on our website we break it down into
what we call
kind of the stoplight colors right um
green yellow red so is this facility
high cost you're gonna be paying more
than the market rate
is it yellow it's kind of in the middle
is it green is it below market rate
that's a little bit where data science
comes in
um so it's actually another team that
supports the model but we have some
effort around
um classifying uh
facilities as green yellow or red and a
little bit more goes into it than cost i
can't give all the secret information
um but we have classification models
that actually do that on the cost side
so that's one example
um
an example on the quality side is
around prediction of patient outcomes
so
healthcare quality is a little bit of an
abstract um thing i guess
you know when you think about healthcare
quality there's no real accepted
definition of what me what it means to
have quality healthcare
there's a lot of guidance out there i
mean this is something that's been
around probably since the 60s
and it's mostly guided by what's called
the don obedient model
which is a framework of how we measure
healthcare quality
within the system that we have
so
many companies including ours take the
approach and including cms as well um
the government also takes the approach
of
health outcomes as being a major
indicator for quality so did the person
have a pressure ulcer did the person get
sepsis while they were in an inpatient
stay you know things like that
um so
for specific patient outcomes
we support regression models um
surrounding really four main patient
outcomes um across many procedures
um it's really very broad at axial we
had a large focus on drug addiction
mostly related to opioids
blue book really covers the spectrum so
we have four different patient outcomes
that we model through regression models
that basically says um
essentially do we expect through the
regression models
did the with the person based on their
patient profile their comorbidities
would they have expected to have a poor
outcome and an inpatient stay
versus did they actually have the
outcome and the the idea behind that is
if the
if the person actually didn't have the
outcome but they were expected to have
it then that gap is where really quality
lies because the assumption is that the
provider or the facility
made some sort of intervention
that would have prevented an otherwise
poor outcome
so those are the two examples that i can
give where data science
contributes to our business
um i'll give one more example so those
two examples i gave it's important to
realize those are
that's information that goes to our
products
uh we also have an effort around
internal optimization
um so it's around um
engagement of clients so as you can well
imagine
some of the
biggest challenges that we have as a
company is actually getting people to
use the website
so it's actually getting the consumer to
engage with us log on search for
their particular healthcare procedure so
that's more difficult than you might
think
so we have an ongoing effort
to understand really kind of consumerism
in terms of why do people use our
website who uses it who doesn't use it
who
interacts with a health care system and
has blue book as an option but doesn't
go there and why don't they go there
and so so really what i'm talking about
is um heavily related to retail right
why do people purchase certain things
um
so we have an ongoing effort to try to
understand that data just in terms of
who uses our product why do they use it
how do they use it
and can we potentially intervene in some
way to increase those numbers and
actually save people more money
very good and and phil uh made a comment
or okay comment have question i'm uh
i'll phil i'll give you a
chance to uh yeah i'm in
yeah thanks uh i'm gonna save on video
because i've got a bandwidth issue here
um thanks yeah i was really interested
in your introduction you talked a little
bit about
a mind
set change when you were
in the transition between the
organizations i'm curious to understand
kind of what that
change was with with aspects changed
yeah gosh i could talk about this for
the next five hours actually um so i'll
try to shorten it a little bit um so
you know i most of my experience
um really until that point has been in
an academic laboratory and
you know the incentives and the work
styles in that scenario are very
different than a for-profit business you
have to think a little bit more
strategically about things like time to
market
um you know adoptability um
interpretability of the models like you
don't really i'm not saying you don't
have to think about that in academia but
there there was less of a focus there
let's say than as opposed to sort of a
small startup business so
i was really kind of designing projects
that were maybe
medium medium to long-term
projects
i was really had a very like data first
mindset in terms of like i'm presented
with a business problem and i'm
immediately thinking what fancy model
can i build
um and i really had to kind of shift how
i think about that
because there really is
you know a lot to consider around just
business structure
in terms of growth opportunities market
opportunities that you have to think
about in order to be a good data
scientist and have a really high
functioning data science team
so
i had to learn
and i made a lot of missteps honestly
early on
but i really had to learn from a network
of great mentors that i was able to
build over time
like how do i position myself position
my team strategically
within a company to
really let us be as effective as we can
possibly be for the business and
that could mean a lot of things i'm not
trying to be too vague about it but it
could mean
that
i'm a little more deliberate around
partnering with our account team our
sales team our product team
sort of figuring out how do i work with
these teams most effectively what kinds
of questions do i need to ask them how
do i speak the language of the business
to get them to understand things like
model performance
and how does it bring risk to the
business or not
um so that's really what i'm talking
about when i say that i had to really
kind of shift my mindset a lot i started
reading a lot of business books i
started listening to a lot of products
data product podcasts
um i actually have this one book i'm
rereading it so it's mckenzie and
companies valuation
measuring and managing the value of
companies like this is not a data
science book by any means
but
i think it's a good example and what i
really encourage data scientists to
think about is
really taking some time to study the
business and understand what is your
c-suite thinking
you know if you feel misunderstood about
kind of your team or what you bring to a
business
then i think it's important to kind of
start talking their language and sort of
understanding where they're coming from
um something that's come up recently
in terms of our own product strategy and
business strategy as a data science team
i'm starting to think about okay
the the projects that we have currently
if we are in a growth time of the
business
do any of these projects can i
specifically tie them to more revenue
growth in the next six months 12 months
whatever the time period might be right
um
i think a good data science leader sort
of thinks about those things i mean
maybe it's my opinion
but i've really kind of come to that
conclusion over the years that
you know no one really wants to geek out
with me about the latest data science
models except for my team right
um and so
you know i have to kind of speak their
language in a lot of ways and i find it
really interesting i think um
i think a lot about
data science and bringing science to
people to help people
and what that means to a business and
how do i communicate it
um
i just i think it's something that's
really misunderstood and even you know i
don't get right a lot of times either
and so i've just i have found that to be
a very compelling piece of my transition
out of academia
perfect thank you
prabha has his hand raised over to you
hi lindsey thanks for the introduction
and talk okay i have two questions
when you your previous answer touched
upon portion of that my first question
which is what are your measures and
metrics of success you talked about
revenue growth yeah
prior to
uh you know
if you go back maybe a year or further
back what were the previous measures of
success that you had with your company
before revenue growth crossed your mind
or
is part of your portfolio
the second question that i have is
you're in the health care insurance
industry
it is my perception or knowledge that
there is a boundary to in healthcare
industry to which um open source tools
can be used uh when i think of pharma
companies for
you know uh
or there is some portion of healthcare
industry where open source tools cannot
be used because you need to have a
liability or a tracking um and though so
you need products like sas or uh
that can you know somebody takes the
liability for it um so these are my two
questions i want to uh
understand you know what were your
previous metrics of success first
question second one is what is the
boundary in healthcare industry for open
source technologies to be utilized
okay great question so i'll start start
with your second question first um
so
you know it is
i would say a concern
certainly privacy and data security is a
concern
um i would say at my last company in
this company too we are open source
focused um so we actually have hybrid
deployments currently in both python and
r
for data science
on our development side we also have
things written in python so that's
obviously an open source tool
um
we currently have a hybrid also
infrastructure
between on-prem and cloud
bluebook's been around a little over a
decade now so really at that time
building cloud infrastructure wasn't
really what people did mostly because of
security concerns so
we early on had clients who did not want
their data to be in the cloud
and at the time
this isn't true now but up until
recently
microsoft would would not allow
a specific time for data breach
um notifications to be had so it was it
was too long to actually satisfy our
clients
um so
for for reasons like that you know maybe
we weren't able to utilize certain cloud
infrastructure tools
that we would have otherwise but i would
say for us it's been not so much a
question of open source tools
but more of like on-prem versus cloud
platforms as to where we could
potentially go
now axial actually started in a cloud
infrastructure
so it was a little bit different at that
company we didn't really have the same
problem sets that we have now we just we
just have different problems than we can
i guess
but but really
most of our security concerns have been
around data warehousing and storage
and also i would add to that
data retention policies
that we have had to fulfill for certain
clients
around that so i would say i have
personally not experienced
security problems with using some open
source tooling
it's more been around the the platforms
that we have
um
okay i'll go to your second question now
so
measuring
success and roi for data science team so
i think this is a really interesting
question um i'll give you some sense of
how we i've done in the past i do it now
and then i'll
sort of give my overall sense um
so at axial we had
a few different um
measures of success for the team which
were kind of interesting i've never
really seen anybody do this other than
us but um we had
one measure was conversion rate of
projects so we had a mindset
at least after the first couple years it
was we didn't really have any measures
for a couple years that i was there
and then i developed some for the team
in conjunction with my current leader at
the time so
one of them was project conversion so
how many projects come to us and what
percent is actually converted to an
actual deployment
so
our target was about five percent and i
know that sounds really low
but our idea was that we want to fail
fast we want to fail often it's kind of
like a drug discovery mentality it's
like if things aren't going to work we
want to know early on and then we want
to get rid of it
so we had a 5
project conversion to deployment rate
target
we also had targets around the number of
specific models that we wanted in what
we called our data science portfolio
library
so they didn't necessarily have to be
like really fancy machine learning
things a lot of them were kind of
business logic sort of ranking models
um but we had sort of data science
portfolio targets i can't remember an
actual number um i don't
yeah i can't remember remember the
actual number but that was one of the
measures
um and then
secondly was around like
sort of product value could we pinpoint
that our model went into the data
product and it resulted in more clients
contracting with us
or um
a greater revenue because we were able
to kind of upsell a data product due to
the fact that we had added another
feature um so we had some financial
targets around that
so that's kind of how we handled it at
axial
blue looks a little bit different in
that i'm not really sure
you know honestly up until this point
we've only had a formalized data science
team since september
when i worked at blue book
before the acquisition i was the single
data science person
and i worked actually on the engineering
i.t side
now since september we do have a
formalized data science team
so i'm currently working on sort of met
success measures and kind of what that
looks like
so i don't have a lot of specificity for
you in my current role but i can say
that we do utilize the
outcomes and key results
strategy that is published in a book
called measure what matters i think the
author is door i believe
if you've never read measure what
matters i would highly recommend it
i also posted on linkedin today katie
nuggets came out with um
part one top data science books ever
published i thought that was really good
so i think somebody mentioned a chat
about book recommendations i read books
all the time
um especially big
business ones so anyway that was a side
note um
so we use the okr method of planning
and so essentially we plan objectives
and key results and we do this by
quarter we've done this since i've been
at blue book
so we we have targets that are set every
quarter
um so projects really only last three
months in duration
um now you might be asking yourself well
what if a model bill takes longer
um i think we'll cross that bridge when
we come there we actually haven't
experienced that yet
um but we we try to and i try to plan
for both myself and my team to have
projects that are really in no longer
than three-month increments in order to
kind of keep things going and sort of
satisfy the business
so i know that's not very specific in
terms of roi
um
i will kind of end this by saying i
think the data science roi is really
just a difficult thing to measure at
times
my point of view is that i believe data
science is a little bit of
a capital expense at times it's a little
bit of a luxury especially for small
businesses that are not specifically ai
focused
and so i think sometimes you have to
look at it as this is a team that's
going to do high-risk projects they're
going to do research things are going to
fail a lot and that's okay
because we're willing to invest the you
know whatever amount it is three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand dollars a
year in personnel salary for our small
team
and be able to
absorb that cost in terms of what we
potentially get out of the team in terms
of algorithmic deployed solutions
or specific insights and research
um that are valuable to the business
okay all in that there any more
questions around that
thanks for that yeah um that was
very detailed
absolutely
there is actually i'll add on linkedin
there is a linkedin influencer i guess
his name is vin viscasta
um and he is a data scientist consultant
and he publishes a newsletter on
substack and a lot of information around
how to measure data science value
um so i would recommend him also as a
resource around that
i see a question in the chat from aj aj
i'll give you a chance to jump in and
ask it live
if not i can always ask it for you
take that
i'll ask it
being in data science you must get a lot
of reporting requests is there a
blueprint you follow to streamline
things like data modeling development to
a finished report given there are so
many data sources in organizations today
like erp systems flat file sharepoint
etc something that saves you time thanks
okay great question um okay so do we get
a lot of reporting requests
um actually kind of no we we did it
axial we got tons of them
um at blue book we do have a dedicated
client reporting analytics team
and we've been pretty successful i think
about
um
making sure that people know that that
is the reporting structure at blue book
so if if clients need customized reports
or if there's questions about
ongoing deployed reports that are
typically
either in like power bi
or i think some of them are actually
still like excel based type stuff
then it really kind of goes to that team
i will say that we do get a lot of
ad hoc requests in terms of what i would
what i would characterize as
um
like pilot type work
and um
i typically fulfill that
um however i really do always advocate
for
um sort of quick decisions in terms of
like do we
do we know what we want the outcome of
this pilot to be
if we don't we have to define that
and if when we define it we come back to
the table and say okay it was a success
or failure if it was a failure we move
on
if it was a success then we turn this
into
a more deliberate project and we have a
scalable deployment strategy
for that pilot stuff
so that's really a big piece of my job
is to i don't want to say protect my
team
but it's a little bit like that it's
it's basically like kind of keeping
everyone on track and saying okay you
know we
we have to really think very clearly
about what we're doing in terms of kind
of one-off work
because you can drown in it very rapidly
in terms of like that's all you're doing
all the time so
that's part of my job is to kind of be a
little bit of a gatekeeper there
um let's see
given that there's so many data sources
um
yeah like i said we don't really do
reporting now
but we do
have
a lot of documentation that we support
for the business in terms of methodology
so that's probably the most closely
related thing to a report
um we our documentation is currently
just in like pete static pdfs that get
versioned
um we're also we're trying to think a
little bit outside the box of how to do
that a little more clearly i brought up
the idea of making
tick tock videos of our methods
i don't know if that landed very well i
would love it but
you know i just think you know clients
it can come across as kind of dry i mean
let's be honest sometimes data science
and talking about an algorithm can be
boring to a lot of people
and so i think anytime we can make it
fun accessible
think about different platforms in which
we communicate methods and why we're
doing things i think is always good
can i ask what is the calculus in your
head when you get an ad hoc request like
you said you typically
say yes i'm just curious what your
thought process is
yeah so when i so typically it comes in
the form of some some kind of already
ongoing project
um
typically the calculus is in my head is
usually to i don't want to say push back
but i always make sure
that we're all on the same page in terms
of what the objective of the request is
and that can typically get me to where i
need to be just in terms of getting to
people to think about because clients
ask for things all the time i'm sure
that you all experience this as well in
your own roles
um you know there it's kind of a
never-ending battle for different
requests different numbers this than the
other i think it's always important to
kind of take a little bit of a deep
breath and say okay
do we understand why this person is
asking this is there a deficiency
potentially in our reporting structures
or our product that's not meeting client
needs if so we need to
pencil that in and address it
or is this someone who's you know trying
to kind of get some free analytical work
done which happens right
um so that's kind of the calculus that
goes on in my head i mean certainly
working for a small business um
you know you're never really going to
get away from ad hoc work pilot work
i've read blogs before that a lot of
companies it's like death by a thousand
pilot projects because everything's
always a pilot it never really becomes
like an actual product
um you know i've seen that happen
periodically for sure
um so really the calculus in my head is
is typically one of do we understand
what the objective is does it fall in
line with our current
company objectives
does it fall in line with
our vision for what the data product
actually does in the market that we sell
to
um so that's typically how i'm thinking
there is a list of anonymous questions
that i that
we should get to um
actually right out of the gates so i'm
very sorry that we're just getting to it
now uh i noticed that you have your mbti
on linkedin any tips for those with less
common personality types in the
workforce i am an intj
okay um
you know look i i know that the science
behind is kind of weak but i'm a big fan
of personality tests particularly
leading people i think it's really
important to understand the person how
they work
um it's it's something that was also
sort of brought up in kind of leadership
um training
um
look i think
there's room for all different
personality types within data science or
any field for that matter i think the
important thing is to
really understand your own value
proposition i think this kind of speaks
to kind of branding
i get a lot of career questions and do a
lot of career talks and panels and
things like that and
i'm a big proponent of of branding i
think it's important to
get your github together you know have
your linkedin profile up to speed put
put some time and curation there so
i think it's really important to kind of
define for yourself who are you what do
you offer
to a data science team or to whomever
kind of you work for
[Music]
um and i think there's room for all
personality types it's just it's really
up to you for you to define for yourself
how does that particular type
what what benefits does it kind of play
within the grand scheme of what you want
to do or accomplish at a company
any tips for working at a smaller
company how do you handle
underperforming colleagues when there
isn't a lot of space for error
that's a great question um okay well my
tip for working in a small company is
like things move quickly and you
to say that i'm a data scientist or even
a director of data science is probably
inaccurate and
i have to do some product development i
have to do people influencing i have to
do c-suite influencing
i have to do some marketing
i have to talk with clients i do that
often actually i'm brought into methods
discussions
so i have to be an account manager at
times
um
so i think that's the key like i think
being successful in a data science role
at a small company or really any role
for that matter really requires you to
think of yourself more broadly
i can make another book recommendation
it's called range by david epstein
anybody read this any hands
give me an emoji or something um
i have read it
this is a really good book that also
heavily changed my perspective of who i
am
um just as a scientist and kind of what
i offer so i think
you know my biggest um
sort of thing at
working at a small company my biggest
piece of advice is you have to be a
generalist you kind of have to wear a
lot of hats you have to sometimes put on
your engineering hats your dba hat your
data science hats
and some people don't thrive in that
environment and that's okay
um
there was a second part to that question
i'm sorry i got sidelined by my book
recommendation um
it was around under performance
in a startup
yeah that's true um you know i think the
biggest piece in working for for a
startup and i think this is true across
the board
but
um you know the thing is
you really have to be comfortable
with
very open-ended work
and
typically folks who are just starting
out who are pretty junior
they have a hard time with that
you know someone gives me something to
work on and it's like super vague
um you know what am i going to do with
that i'm going to use my expertise to
kind of figure it out i'm going to
consult google i mean you know i've
heard me i've seen memes about like the
number one job skill is knowing how to
google properly i think there's a lot of
truth to that right so it's really being
able to take like very little
information
and provide something back to the
business that is meaningful
and i think junior folks have a really
hard time with that i think it's a very
i think for some people it's a very
innate skill i think for others it's
something i have to develop over time
and then i think a third group of people
never develop it
and so um
you know folks who are underperforming
are typically folks who really can't
handle work like that
and so the way that i approach that is
typically through a training exercise
you know i i work with them instead of
telling them what to do i say
what do you think the next step is you
know can you write me a plan of what
you're going to do in order to execute
on this project and can we kind of work
through that together
there's not really a specific playbook
per se for that
um
but one truth i've learned is that when
you don't really know what to do
in a project
the best thing to do is eda start with
exploratory data analysis understand the
data
um like for example
you know in our engagement work
really the
the first question i had was well how
many people use our website
i mean just a basic question
that maybe hadn't really been explored
very deeply
but knowing those basic things about
where we are now and this is part of
data science strategy or strategy with
any team like assessing where we are
present day
is always really that good first step
when you really don't know what to do in
a project so that's how i sort of
approach an underperformer
um
i think it also
it can't be sort of said enough just
basic communication sort of
understanding where they are what are
their goals
in my experience people who have
underperformed um
have typically ended up leaving um on
their own
and there's usually a
again in my experience uh an
understanding mutually that it's just
not a great fit for whatever reason so
it kind of typically works itself out in
that way honestly
there's a question from sloan i'll give
you the opportunity to ask if you'd like
or feel comfortable
sure um nice to meet you lindsay
um i am fairly early in my career i've
got a couple years of experience as a
data scientist
and
i think i could probably do some work on
my personal brand and so i wanted to ask
if you have any suggestions on
really how to build a brand when you're
just starting out
yeah so that's a great question um i
think there are a couple things and kd
nuggets they actually published i i
posted it on my linkedin uh you can find
it there
or maybe just search their website they
they gave a blog piece on how to build a
portfolio
and i thought it was really good
they basically went through the
different platforms that you could use
so
you know what are the common ones github
with your code
and also probably down to describe it
linkedin is a good platform people
sometimes use social media sites as
platforms so facebook
instagram twitter even
so
you know yes somebody um posted the link
that's exactly right so
i think choosing your platform and your
medium is something that's important to
do kind of early on some people build
their own website or use something like
wordpress or something like that um
you know really the biggest barrier i
find with people starting out is they
don't really have any content right
to me the number one best way is to
actually volunteer for a meet up
speaking engagement and get somebody to
record you speaking and teaching a group
of people something about your work
it doesn't have to be advanced
i have lots of videos on my linkedin of
where i've had speaking engagements and
really i just started out i agreed to a
meetup one day and they recorded it and
i'm like well i'll put this on my
linkedin
and it really just kind of snowballed
from there so it's always amazing to me
how many people
starting out don't really take those
opportunities that are so easy to get in
terms of speaking engagements and being
in front of a crowd i know that it can
be intimidating
but really a lot of meetups
and even and the ones in nashville are
the same
they're they're very much
geared toward people who are new
um at their very grassroots kind of
efforts
and so they're very open and welcoming
to anybody with any sort of skill level
coming and talking about a topic or
teaching the group about something
that's one of the easiest ways to start
building content for your brand which is
typically
um
you know video
um or you know it can be text you know
i'd put some time thinking about your
bio and linkedin and sort of that
um running a blog is the next best way
um i have a small blog that i probably
need to pay more attention to but
really just putting something out there
just in terms of like your point of view
on a particular topic it really could be
anything
um it could be data science strategy it
could be leadership it could be from the
point of view of someone who's very
junior and how they're feeling about how
they're being led i've not really seen
that perspective a lot and i think that
would be really impactful
um
so those are a few different
ways um
i would also encourage you guys to also
post on linkedin
the more that you can kind of post
things and share content
then the easier it gets
it just kind of
exercises that muscle a little bit and
people
will like your content or they'll share
it and it really just kind of gets the
ball rolling so
those are my biggest pieces of advice
just choose your platforms and then
start building content and find kind of
low barrier ways to do that
thank you i have not heard the
meet up piece of advice before so that's
that's a good nugget that i'll i'll
definitely hopefully use in the future
yeah i'm sure everyone's located
different places and
you know most every city even smaller
cities even knoxville we have meetups
here
um so even if you're not in a place
where there is a large tech meetup um
sort of scene
you can always find like you know
philadelphia or san francisco or maybe
austin texas like they all have meetups
that i'm sure you could reach out to
organizers and
i know from experience as an organizer
they're always very hungry to find
presenters
and so they'll pretty much always say
yes
um so it's very low barrier to entry
thank
you
there's a similar uh somewhat similar
question that was submitted anonymously
how do you get started with speaking
engagements
yeah
meetups to me are the best way number
the number one way to get started
and then
i know in nashville we have an annual
analytics summit
that it's mostly local people that come
to you
and so you can apply
you can submit an abstract for a talk
so just just finding those kinds of
different platforms where you know you
can give a talk or you know
you really can't discount and i know
it's hard it's hard starting out but if
you
really take the time to like volunteer
yourself people are always looking for
help
and so it really just takes
it's kind of like you know tamping down
the imposter syndrome
and putting yourself out there and
saying i want to do this i mean you
you'd be surprised at how many wins you
can really get by just raising your hand
and saying i'm available
i would love this opportunity do you
have any opportunities yeah the answer
might be no sometimes and that's okay
you just move on to the next thing
there's a question
any thoughts on sites like good rx
which seems similar but for shopping for
prescriptions
yeah so we currently do have a
prescription um
product an rx product that's relatively
new at blue book
um
so i mean my thoughts on goodrx i've
used goodrx so you know i liked it
because i saved on my prescription
um
i don't know that i have any thoughts on
it other than i have
heard through the grapevine from
pharmacy friends that they don't like it
because i think administratively it's
actually very difficult
um
but
you know i think any time you can use
something to empower a patient and i
think that's really why i like blue book
i think it's fair to say
that our health care system is
very broken it's 20 of our entire gdp in
the united states which is nuts
another book recommendation i can make
is called an american sickness
it's a book about the history of our
health care system and how health care
insurance actually came to be
and it really breaks down
administratively how different entities
within the healthcare landscape work
it's really really interesting read it's
also frustrating
because i actually read it right before
i came to blue book and one thing i
really like about blue book is that we
are really devoted to helping the
patients
our products and services are very
patient-centric and go directly to the
patients themselves
so i personally like that about the
company
i think i like goodrx because again it's
really devoted to helping patients save
money
um
i don't know that i would consider
goodrx a direct competitor of ours
necessarily
i think we offer just a little bit
something different than
um
but i like it that's my opinion
question about regulatory things uh when
dealing with healthcare or patient data
how do you ensure that back end
infrastructure is compliant to use aws
or some other vendors
so our cloud
pieces are on azure
and we do go through what's called
hytrust and stock certification
i actually don't know the
i think we've passed one of them and not
the other so far i don't know it takes a
really long time to get so
high trust and stock are really the two
biggest kind of
compliance sort of
check boxes i guess you might say that
that a company like ours who's
considered a third party associate can
kind of go through
a lot of people don't know this but
hipaa does not provide any sort of
guidance as to what specific security
controls that you have to have in place
it just says that it has to be secure
and that's it
so
a lot of people don't realize that so
you know
high trust and sock certifications were
really created to kind of address some
of those
you know can we provide
specificity around what needs to be in
place in order to really say that we're
secure
um so we go that route i mean certainly
both aws and azure have products in
place that they sort of bill as hipaa
compliant which really means that it has
encryption or other types of controls in
place
that would
benefit us from in terms of having a
data breach
um so that those are the types of things
we do and it's not different than any
other healthcare i t company
i just want to be
mindful of time do you have a few
minutes or you have a heart
i have until three o'clock
very good
um
so i asked this question with caution so
it's anonymous question and you don't
have to answer it i say that because the
hangout is not supposed to be about our
studio products at all but there's an
anonymous question how is bluebook using
our studio what tools are you utilizing
feel free to be as general or a closed
mouth as you'd like
sure so i'm a big fan of r uh you know
right now we do have hybrid deployment
and data science at blue book so we have
things in both python and our
of course python and are not the only
games in town but i think that's mostly
what people use um
so our regression models for quality are
currently scripted and are
using the rms package
um
we have kind of a
i don't know what you would really call
it um to me it's not
what people would consider a true
deployment because a lot of the stuff
that we do is really batch in nature
right
and i think this is not talked enough
about in the data science community that
sometimes you really don't need
like
you know api calls and sort of you know
there's no reason to build in kind of
functionality in which a user would be
selecting data and you would be doing
predictions on the fly
like we don't have that we just don't
have the business case for it so
we currently do have batch scripts that
run on spark
for our regression models
and then
we have deployments in python for other
types of algorithms so what i mean by
that is we have some basic statistics
stuff
um we have
a fuzzy matching for some of our data
cleaning efforts that are scripted in
python
i support those myself they run mostly
through cron jobs on linux servers
um so that's kind of the landscape of
deployment for the most part i mean it's
more nuanced than that but i would say
that's most of what we do um
you know i think our
we used the fully paid kind of
r studio at axial and we really liked it
um
and it was again sort of the same thing
we had batch scripts that ran once a
month and they were kicked off manually
it wasn't like a scheduled job or
anything like that
you know i'm not as hardcore maybe as
some people like i think if the
deployment scheme works and you have
really appropriate qa and controls and
things like that i'm a big fan of
logging as well if those things are in
place i think it's fine
um
you know
again like it doesn't have to be like
this full-fledged
sort of
totally hands-off entirely 100 automated
scripting kind of modality right
um but that's how we use our currently
at blue book and i don't really see that
changing
very good so i want to end on um
a topic that has uh come up a lot at
these hangouts and i i thought of the
question when you gave a previous answer
so you wake up one day and
you say i have to work with other
functions i'm a data scientist these
other functions are not data science
teams you need to work with product or
engineering or the c-suite like how do
you go about
doing that like you just wake up and
start doing it
uh it's a great question i i would say
well no you don't really just start up
and wake up and start doing it um i
would say there's really been two things
i've done
um
to
sort of be that person
and um one of them is fine mentorship um
i think that
is an underrated
thing i i think a lot of i've mentored
some college students and honestly i
feel like i've not really been very
useful to them because
i think college students and folks
starting out really need a different
flavor of mentorship
i think once you've been working for a
few years at least maybe up to five
years then you really start thinking wow
i really need somebody i can lean on to
talk about my problems essentially and
give me advice
and so really through my leadership
training
and then really just my involvement in
the community and talking to a few
people
or several people i mean
it's really become apparent to me that
having really strong mentorship is
really key to that um so people can give
you advice in terms of what mistakes
that they've made in the past how
they've approached talking to the
c-suite or whatever the case may be
you know i think one thing i've really
learned in terms of leaders it's not
just c-suite it's you know management
that's above you
i think oftentimes
they are more
willing and wanting to talk to you and
hear your ideas than you might think
i think there's sometimes a perception
that they sort of live in this very like
they're very
mature and they've got all the answers
and you know that's really almost never
the case i mean i think in my experience
your leadership really does want to hear
from you and i think
sometimes they don't really provide
obvious ways for you to do that and so i
think
it's really kind of a
an exercise and kind of taking it upon
yourself to find those
ways that you can interact with them and
talk to them in kind of meaningful and
sort of low stress environments
it could be taking them to lunch one day
i mean i know we work in a mostly remote
environment now so that's a little bit
harder
but just finding ways that you can
connect with them
i think is important
and your mentors can help you sort of
figure out what those ways are
the second thing that i've done is i
read
i read a lot of books um yes i'm one of
those people who actually reads physical
books still
um i listen to a lot of podcasts
um actually one of my favorite podcasts
is um pivot if anyone knows scott
galloway he's an economist at nyu i'm a
huge scott galloway fan like
probably so good probably unhealthy but
i love scott galloway and i listen to
all of his podcasts and looks like
robert's with me in the fan club
um and you know listening to just like
business oriented things i think has
really helped me again talk about data
science very differently
instead of talking about the algorithm
and and you know i've interviewed a lot
of data scientists over time right and
not that this is necessarily a red flag
but 95 of the data science interviews
that i have
asked this person to tell me about a
project and they immediately go into the
r library or what package they use or
the algorithm
i actually don't want to hear about that
i want to hear about what was the
problem you were trying to solve why did
you think a data science solution was
appropriate did you consider another
solution
can you talk about it in terms of what's
written in mckinsey's book
as opposed to very scientific terms
right you know that's typically what i'm
looking for in very experienced high
performers
is that they they talk about data
science work very differently
um
so those are really the two things that
i've done over time to kind of get me to
this point and i'm still not there
i think it'll be a lifelong journey
quite frankly but i think once you
really start to
understand the landscape of data science
and how it fits into different sized
businesses
um
then
i just i think there just gets to be
this kind of turning point in your life
and i just personally it's resonated
with me i've really enjoyed
um the prospect of
making my science very real to a
consumer and i love that
yeah
before we go i'm going to hold you to a
tangible piece of
advice so like what is the if you could
think of it the
crawl walk run for like someone who's
just starting out in their career to
actually like get exposure with
leadership or other functions like is it
a weekly email or
you know five minutes stand up once a
week
yeah it's a great question a couple
things i've done that have been
successful are
asked to go to meetings
so if you know that there's a standing
leadership meeting
some of them you know they might not
want everybody in right but if there's
some sort of like
product focused meeting or i mean you
just get to know what happens at your
company right so i think that's a really
good way
it's a very low barrier way to get some
of that exposure i think anytime you can
get exposure to what is discussed on
other teams it is a win
it does take time it takes time out of
your day
but it doesn't really affect the meeting
it doesn't affect the flow of business
and so
just ask to sit in on stuff right um
yeah you might be told no for certain
reasons and that's okay
um but i think a lot of people will
appreciate your willingness
to really want to learn other aspects of
the business i mean i have found that
always to be true
um that just me saying hey i want to
learn more about this can i sit in on
one of your meetings can i maybe sit in
on a client call
um
i mean i've always been told yes 100 of
the time so um
that's a really easy way to do it
um i think
going to local meetups or networking
events that are geared toward leader
professionals
i think is another way to gain that
exposure
um
really just talking to people who do
this kind of stuff
i have had less success with what's
called informational interviews so one
of the career
pieces of advice that i got early on was
do an informational interview find
somebody who has the job you want
and reach out to them and say hey i
would love to learn more about what you
do i've done that a handful of times
it's typically
the people i've talked to have really
kind of hated their jobs
so it never really worked out for me
that good but
i do think it's still a good way to go
like if you can
again invite somebody for coffee say i
would love to meet you and learn more
about what you do i mean really that's
how i got my first
startup job at axial is i just reached
out to them and say hey
like i would love to come visit your
company and just like be a little fly on
the wall for the day are you willing to
do that and they said yes
and so it completely snowballed into
you know a professional networking
relationship so
my biggest piece of advice is
it really doesn't matter what you do
just do something right just take that
first step it doesn't have to be the
right step
it doesn't have to be the right person
um but but do something to kind of kick
start that and do it regularly
that's my biggest advice
very good awesome stuff so so how can
people get in touch with you
if they would like to
yeah so the biggest way to get in touch
with me is on linkedin i'm on linkedin
all the time
i have my phone app
i do just a lot of linkedin stuff i
learned a lot from linkedin i follow
influencers i keep up with data science
news that way so
please happy to connect with any of you
on linkedin
um
i think my email is listed on there but
you can always message me on linkedin i
have the paid linkedin version or
whatever so you can drop me a note
if you'd like my email or whatever but
uh that's absolutely the best way to get
in touch with me
very good well thank you so much for the
time i don't know if you had an
opportunity to look at all the uh
comments in the
chat yeah everyone thought you were
great you really were um so
thanks everyone for attending and
sticking around and uh lindsay i'm sure
we'll be in touch next week rachel will
be back so you know thank god for that
already y'all uh have a great day thank
you thanks everybody
you